Welcome to Lee's Detective Agency.
We accept every manner of requests
and will do our best to meet your needs
in goods delivery, pick up,
infiltration, investigation,
arbitration, and conflict resolution.
We can solve *anything* in Lungmen
except for detective work because that's police business...
please don't expect this to be a detective show.
A Day of Perfection
Uncle Tung?
Waai Fu.
Did Jaye swing by your place?
No.
What's going on?
Well.
I'm warning you again. Not with your hands. You'll get hurt.
I need 5 pounds of fins and 5 pounds of shrimps.
The juicier, the better.
Hey!
And that was how Jaye was taken away.
A group of people in suits?
Do they look like this?
Well.
Yeah. They do look like this.
Did Jaye mention where he was going?
No.
Jaye here.
Can't pick up the phone right now.
Leave your message after the beep.
This smells like the Cats.
I got this. Go home, Uncle Tung. And lock your doors and windows.
You know where he is?
I'll look around the theater.
Hi.
I knew the Cat Mafia won't give up like this!
Despicable.
How dare they seek revenge on simpletons!
Don't rush into things.
Are you really sure it's the Cat Mafia?
They're right in front of us.
We've been watching them for the entire day.
Nobody came out of the place.
Huh? Then who's the culprit?
Jaye!
Place is booked for a private show. Invited guests only.
Meow.
Do you really expect that to work?
Situation normal.
Roger.
Situation looks normal here as well.
Who asked you to come here?
Fate.
The injustice of fate called me here.
The sound effects are too realistic!
Then why are you here?
I'm here to take back what belongs to me.
Get out of here!
I refuse!
Waai Fu.
Found him!
We got a situation.
Stop right there!
Sorry.
I need to explain what's going on.
About that ruckus,
that girl is actually my friend.
What the?
Are you alright?
You made a mistake.
I was watching a play with them.
I have to tell Lady Zhu that I need to go.
What do you mean? I thought you were kidnapped.
No. This is my job.
His job?
What a weird old man.
He pays people just to watch plays with his little girl.
As the heiress of Hatton Hotels, is there anything that troubles you?
I actually
wish to make a few friends.
We can watch plays and chat together.
That's right.
Really?
I didn't expect that.
She wants friends?
Things that money can buy won't last.
And why do you need that much money anyway?
I want to buy a house.
You'll never afford one if you keep working with me.
I know.
So when will you leave me everything you own?
*LUNGMEN EXPLETIVE*
Please find Jaye and bring him back.
Jaye was taken away from the fish stand by mysterious people in suits this morning
and is not seen again thereafter.
Having failed to find him, Uncle Tung
came to Lee's D.A to file a missing person report.
After being shown the photos of Cat Mafiosi, Uncle Tung
suspected that Jaye was taken by the said organization.
The situation is urgent and calls for immediate action!